after looking through the article.really
it almost felt like it was a love letter
to Oklahoma City with Kevin Durant did
you take that away from the
conversations you had with him yeah a
little bit damn I just asked him you
know I asked him Championships aside
just you know how much pride he takes in
kind of what's been built there and when
he looks back we arrived in 2008 ben de
now sort of what he sees and any talked
you know i just talked for a few minutes
about you know the view outside of his
window and all the new businesses going
up and the people and the jobs and I
mean clearly there's a deep satisfaction
in what's been built now how you weigh
that against you know the need to win
the need for championships to kind of
cement players legacies I'm not really
sure you know I don't know how much that
kind of community pride and everything
factors into free-agent decisions but
clearly it means a great deal to him so
I think it's at least it's at least one
factor in the ledger but do you think
that had they bowed out against San
Antonio that that would have had an
effect on his eventual decision to
either stay or leave in Oklahoma City I
feel like every game they're winning
right now is significant as far as I
just I really don't I mean just talking
to kind of people in Oklahoma City
Thunder no one really knows I don't
think what he's going to do or has a
sense for it if I do feel that every
game he wins it let's say they've got
that he likes living there he likes the
community's proud of what they bill
organizationally then it just comes down
to the winning and if you proved this
month potentially next month to that
they can win just like the Spurs and the
Warriors can win these potentially that
it seems even better than those teams
playoffs then I really know how you
validate a move out of there you know it
does feel like every game the Thunder
wins kind of gets him closer to
resigning even if it's a short-term
basis I would think that he would have a
night
what Russell Westbrook wants to do that
that would affect his decision whether
he was going to stay or not and
Westbrook's got another year before he's
up do you feel like they're a package
deal or that they're going to be
together with this you know through the
years I don't know because I mean so
much of that I think it depends on
whether they feel like they can win a
championship together or if they feel as
though hey we've tried this we gave it a
good shot it didn't work I don't really
think it's going to come down to their
personal relationship or their affection
for each other I think that's a dare it
is more do they feel like that
partnership can yield a title or do they
sort of feel like it it's star-crossed
at this point it looks a lot more
promising obviously than it did several
weeks ago and that's why probably if
you're if you're handicapping this thing
the best that would probably be that
Durant does come back for another year
they kind of set up their free agency
situations in line and they both have to
make the decision after next season and
we go through all this all over again
what about more likely to stay if they
win or they lose or does that even know
I'm talk about winning a title yeah I
can imagine walking away they want a
title said I don't think there's any I
think there's any confirmation with
anything in Oklahoma City with him with
the with the way it's run with the
coaching with Westbrook I didn't think
it comes down to he's 27 they've knocked
on the door a lot they have a 1 and
again this is purely this is purely
speculative but I just think there's a
lot of pressure on some of these top
tier megastars to to deliver titles and
if he feels as if he can do it there and
right now it looks a lot more promising
than it did is that I don't see why he
would he would feel the need to walk
away but I do think in the last several
years I mean think about harden in the
Ibaka injury in the Westbrook entry in
his own injury and you know all the
strife there was Reggie Jackson I didn't
get some points it probably you know he
probably surveyed the landscape
especially the season you're looking at
the Warriors the Spurs they never lose
and wondering well why not us and I
think that I think that sentiment
gripped a lot of the NBA this year I'm
sure it was in play Cleveland to
Oklahoma City um but you know it it
shifted and clear
these teams had another gear to get to
and that's where handicapping the
playoffs is tricky you don't really know
if everybody's emptied the barrel and
potentially Oklahoma City just didn't
especially in defense I mean the way
they're applying on defense the waiter
rant playing on defense they didn't
really show that I mean clearly they had
a little bit more to give we're the
Warriors and spurs were probably giving
all these lay Jenkins Sports Illustrated
senior NBA Writer did the profile on
Kevin Durant this week's sports
illustrated is he comfortable being that
big fish in a small pond I feel like
he's changed he's changed that
discussion a little bit because I don't
know that there are small ponds anymore
and it's largely because of him I mean
he's he's gotten everything I think you
know a person could reasonably ask for
from a branding perspective and
commercials and he is that global
celebrity and he did it from Oklahoma
City in it it seems like the math
there's change and he and Westbrook ER I
think largely responsible for it so you
know he thinks of himself he says kind
of a you know a small town kid know he's
from he's from outside DC with school
obviously Texas so I I but I don't think
like from a you know celebrity
standpoint for everything he wants to
accomplish I feel like he can accomplish
it all right there I think that's kind
of that's at this point part of his
legacy to tears at it so many players
now I don't think they have to make a
decision necessarily based on market
size and there are there are many bigger
than Kevin Durant Russell Westbrook why
doesn't you want to be listed as a
7-footer didn't ask about that yeah
that's so common it's like all the big
guys want to be listen listen smaller
and all the small guys wanted to be
listed bigger and useful these guys do
they grow up like I Duran grew up with
the ball in his hand you know all those
big guys say that like grew up playing
point guard even karl-anthony towns I
grew up when point guard and they all it
goes back to a cagey thing right i mean
they all want to be wings or backcourt
guys at harlem ron's like that too and
he still thinks of himself in some ways
as a guard you they want to be power
forwards or centers i guess kind of they
recall someone
or plotting and kind of less agile and
athletic so I mean I kind of get it from
that standpoint but when you sit with
him it's just a striking you know I'm
talking to be a player's all the time
but his length i miss the length of his
arms and legs and any think about the
way Oklahoma City's constructed how
Ibaka looks that way to and Adams and
you know there's a book or the story
where Nagi Mohammed said we can play
small too we just do with seven and i
think that's right i mean there is so
athletic and so long and i think they've
really kind of messed with the ball
movement of San Antonio angle of the
state well congrats again on another
great profile there and thanks for
joining us Lee I appreciate it thank
them mentally Jenkins fort illustrated
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience